Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday. Quick
disclaimer, do NOT try this at home. So I
woke up around 8:30 in downtown LA to meet publicist extraordinaire Elyse Marshall and
best-selling author / old pal
Ransom Riggs who took us to the
building where they filmed part of Blade
Runner which featured a carbonite encased Charlie Chaplin and then we went to
an extremely creepy long abandoned
hospital now sometimes used as a setting
for horror movies. This is the kind of
place Ransom takes his friends, which
won't surprise you if you've read his novel Miss Peregrine's Home for Peculiar Children".
We visited the eerie chapel which
reminded me of my Chaplin days,
a kitchen where patients meals were
cooked, "Oh, God!", "don't don't don't don't don't
don't don't"  "it's the oldest coffee in the world." "don't tell me what's in there
don't tell me what's in there" "just look" "no!" "oh, it's amazing,
it's kind of like Bill Nye" "alright, I'm gonna let the camera look but I'm not gonna look myself."
"Get a little closer. Yeah, there you go." And
there was an endless string of hospital
rooms caked with mildew
and bird dung. So many of the windows were
blown out that it was hard to say for sure
whether the place was inside or outside. And I could hear birds singing
and rodents scurrying in the ceilings.
Like many abandoned buildings, there was
evidence of recent squatters,
poorly spelled graffiti, nasty nasty
water fountains,
but what struck me most were the
skeletal remains of dozens of hospital beds.
And then we made our way down to the basement, finding the morgue.
By this time even Ransom, who is hard to scare,
was getting pretty creeped out. "Jesus!"
[John laughing]. I of course am very
easy to scare, Hank. In an operating room, much of the equipment still there,
miraculously unlooted,
I saw a figure in the mirror, "oh my god!",
and about peed myself before realizing
it was me.
We then found our way to the records
room, full of EKGs of hearts that had stopped
beating decades ago.
Finally, we made our way to the boiler
room - the beautiful dead guts of the hospital.
Hank,  abandoned building scare the crap
out of me, but I love
tunnels. Steam tunnels, storm drains,
sewers, whatever.
but the sewer entrance looked a smidge
unappealing
so instead we fumbled around until we
found the steam tunnels.
"yeah, we're well underground now."
as we continued, it got colder. The walls
narrowed.
"Can you give me the light? Does that end?" [shuffling]
"Uh, it's hard to tell. I should've brought my police flashlight." "Alright, I'm gonna go."
"Okay. That was gross. Don't trip."
That tunnel lead to a flooded
room and then to another tunnel
and then to a huge room, entirely empty
except for this bloody bathtub. Horror movie
leftover - I hope!
By than I'd had enough, and as we
made our way up and out of the hospital's
bowels, I found myself wondering what the
hell I was doing.
It's true that such spaces remind us, in
a scary but seductive way, of our own temporariness
and the relatively short life of all
that we build and do,
and it's true that the abject darkness
of the tunnels
make the world outside impossibly bright and alive, but this is also true: it is nice,
on a Thursday morning in April, to be a
kid for a while,
exploring with old friends, never knowing
what wonder or terror may await
around the corner. And isn't that why we
explore and also why we read and watch
sports and browse Tumblr and study
astrophysics?
whether we're watching horror movies or
accidentally visiting their sets,
I think we're after the terrifying,
awesome, otherworldly feeling
of not knowing what lies in wait. Hank, I'll see you on Friday.